[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au départ c'est encore dans ce
petit temps du paf avec les rôles ou du
jour il y en a deux et ils étaient dans
90 minutes enquête hier sur tmc le
premier au lieu du jour c'est un gars
qui voulait absolument aller voir un
dépanneur lors d'un accident
on ne sait pas pourquoi il voulait aller
voir ce dépanneur mais à mon avis il le
kiff de ouf
regardez bien comment il force c'est
magique que la dépanneuse embarque
l'épave de la voiture un curieux
s'approchent alors attendre un petit peu
qu'on évacue la route
parce que vous allez voir pourquoi ah
non mais là il est en train de
travailler laissez le travailler
l'univers o'gara tout à l'heure mais
l'homme tente tout de même de se
faufiler
ce qui a le don d'agacer jérôme merci
[Musique]
alors 90 minutes enquête et collectionne
les relous visiblement parce que lors
d'un incendie games qui n'a pas arrêté
de se saouler les pompiers pour qu'ils
ne pour ne pas qu'ils mettent de l'eau
dans sa boutique regarde regardez le
tuyau de marché suivants le gonfler nom
qu'ils donnent tout c'est ce que voulait
guy michel madame madame vous a demandé
de me décaler la balle mais est ce que
beaucoup d'ambassades et non vers
l'adour la province en a pas alors
maintenant que vous calmer un petit bout
pour l'instant est ce que je voulais pas
déjà promis un don est ce que je voulais
entendre et j'apprends vite les achats
mais je leur ai promis à part mettre des
mots dans les tailles et de couleurs
ça rend fou qui ont d'autres choses à
faire que de calmer des gens qui sont à
naxos email avec la même question
après si on nous laisse deux minutes et
dieu sait si heures la police mais part
je me doute bien que la police répond
pas non plus de la même manière que cote
quand une caméra quand y'en a pas oui on
voit qu'ils sont adorables la personne
s'énerve six fois qu'elle mais vous
monsieur je pense que sans caméra c'est
ferme ta gueule et métaux alors je suis
arrêtée deux fois hier à caméra que vous
dire que c 'est pas écouté calme et
voilà cinq ans à l'époque ils vous ont
dit ça tu fait moins le malin de leurs
mots voilà et bars à quai depuis 20
minutes chez les spurs auraient pas eu
du calme toi bébé s'il va te plaire
faut-il à personne n'aimait pas ou des
noms mais je trouvais que j'ai une
gueule de con non mais voilà c'est qu'il
peut être mais avec des caméras ça comme
ça mais bon je sais que je n'ai pas
d'équipé à tikrit berceau des pompiers
par ailleurs mais sont tombés dans un
guet-apens quand cette semaine à
champigny séquelles très regrettable ans
qui viennent pour ériger faut pas le
faire sombrer sport depuis le carton du
jour c'est le meilleur pâtissier sur m6
hier soir qui a réalisé son record
d'audience de la saison 2 millions 800
mille téléspectateurs 14 5% et la star
du programme cette année c'est mohamed
alors je le crois oui on a un gros point
commun avec mohamed vous allez voir je
vous ai fait une petite compil regarde
ça va dépoter le grand dôme et a plus
que la congélation à vérifier et jeunes
là ça marche
[Musique]
mon royaume pour avoir le génie de la
lampe d'aladin qui sortent mais des
lancements réalisés tous mes voeux de
0,6 oui on les yeux magnifiques tâche et
raisins l'ironie de cette séquence et
que c'est lui qui a été le plus mauvais
mois et est classé en dernier non à la
fin c'est l'ironie d'un celeron du la
séquence le 613 il s'entraîne noël
constamment c'est c'est vraiment petit
une des meilleures saisons à cracher sur
m6 c'est normal d'arriver à temps fou
megaton je m'en fous mais j'adore les
voir fait vous l'avez vu vous le
meilleur pâtissier
moi je le regarde tout le temps mais
l'arrêté de michaels et humoriste on
regarde moi je regarderai fabrice
marbois des liens baisse de mythos va
pas je peux vous montrer et au
restaurant hier soir chez elle et a été
trois copines j'ai craint jamais allé au
restaurant hier à l'été dans le même
restaurant que moi mais bon moi je suis
rentré tous les plus tendres est dans le
pré entre chaurienne il ya eu d'enfants
depuis le début 24 ça va piquer sortie
de l'émission hier la démission j'ai
programmé choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez menti
tapoter sur les murs c'est pas grave
accident pas mais je connais comme ma
vie regardons 49e bien décroche sa mère
ma tante et moi c'est moi
mais les fouilles spectateurs sur target
et le beau gosse et sortir soit
exactement
alors ça c'est dommage et grave qu'elle
ait menti que même moteur graphique il
hier soir je vous dis elle était en
train de dîner avec trois copines à et
le non je vous jure que c'est vrai et je
suis arrivé et ans et je les ai vus les
90 ni de fontenay daniel gillet crois
qu'aucune hier et moi j'aimerais
rajouter quoi du coup vous les avez
invité non non j'ai rongé non non elle
savait déjà payé tout parce que moi je
suis arrivé vraiment très tard en fait
juste pour manger rapidement j'ai mangé
tout seul ah bon mais c'était vous
maintenant j'aime bien manger seul ah
bon c'est vrai mais j'étais surtout pas
de quelle demande du coup leur ep après
après nous a rejoint et en harcèlement
on a parlé de toi tient à lever les buts
un beau [ __ ] véritable chaos journaux
mais c'est vrai que les cueillir c'est
pas une bonne adresse vous êtes allé
lire dans un restaurant dîners seule la
prévention
c'était un lieu non je suis allé vers
moi je suis arrivé à 3-3 entre auxerre
et faire quoi dans la lune
seuls les imitateurs
maintenant c'est vrai était un
restaurant asiatique oui mais voilà
aussi pourquoi que les babas on va mener
une enquête
je dois réfléchir se retrouver à peine
prochaine mais c'est vrai qu'avec mon
portable avec la célébrité eason ça
m'étonne pas c'est que c'est quand on
arrive à paris aussi c'est vrai que le
meilleur pâtissier a très bien marché à
soi mais le vrai carton du jour
ça se passe en inde je ne sais pas si
vous avez vu cette info c'est
complètement ouf mais pour éviter la
triche aux examens
l'université de bagdad en inde a pris
une décision radicale
regardez vous allez comprendre mais moi
on me fait ça en contrôle mais je suis
en race travail et de ou froissé ou ce
qu'ils ont fait quoi regarder avec un
carton sur la tête
impossible de copier sur son voisin
voilà la méthode drastique testé par une
université en inde pour empêcher la
tricherie aux examens ici un partiel de
chimie il y a quand même une ouverture
devant le visage pour voir sa copie et
respirer en découvrant ses photos sur
internet les autorités régionales ont
qualifié la mesure d' inhumaine et la
faculté a dû s'excuser pour sa défense
elle assure que les étudiants étaient
consentants
[Musique]
ces faits main m et moi même imaginer
moralité sa main droite
je me dis je ramenais vos propres cartes
on est malade raconte ben ouais c'est
compliqué non mais c'est vrai
biarritz alors d'ailleurs j'en ai
préparé un pour benji au cas où regarder
tiens mon benji voilà regarde
[Applaudissements]
la défense très beaucoup plus fins comme
ça c'est fou bravo moi tu peux leur
démon benji brom alors c'est de ces
housses et un kit peut être ici à
l'école de voile
mais comment tu fais pour voir avec
bonheur je triche elle avait des
méthodes très très avantagé pour tricher
il faisait quoi il ya des liens très
loin du carton et oui avant on pouvait
photocopier en tout petit ouais il y
avait des verbes irréguliers avait des
grandes pages et moi je m'étais sent
tout petit dans ma trousse juste devant
moi
on dit ça c'est quand même il ya
beaucoup mieux maintenant
ben jabr dans les oreillettes d'accord
dietrich et qui annonce au nom pas
possible j'étais dans une école très il
était très strict sur la discipline
c'est vrai t'as fait quoi comme et
tutoie déjà moi j'ai étudié le vis à vis
du lys mais oui c'est la stricte de vie
c'est-à-dire de réétudier non j'ai fait
des études classiques normal c'est quoi
ou bien un petit peu de langues un petit
peu oui quel ton cursus
c'est quoi la ligue 12 solférino rue du
malgré sa taille des bateaux ça le bac
alors et un baccalauréat plus à l'école
normale sur quoi d'anormal nom des
études classiques noir il à barcus 5 qui
veut pas être invitée mais ça tombe bien
on comptait pas l'invité du jour du tout
c'est michel cina ci était l'invité de
nos confrères de var où il a dit qu'il
voulait venir sur le groupe canal avait
alors déjà il m'a associé à eric zemmour
il a dit eric zemmour et moi rapporté
situés hors du coup il a décidé de
boycotter toutes les émissions du groupe
en mai chelsea mais ce que j'ai jamais
inviter des gens là jamais invité dans
l'émission et il n'y va pas venir ni les
émissions de canal d'ailleurs mais
personne n'a jamais invité monsieur
donné c'est bon mais je pense qu'il
devrait consulter quelqu'un pour avoir
un peu moins le melon parce que là il
part cette girouette l'oeil a même
regardé j'ai décidé de boycotter que le
copiage entendrait pas plus sur la
chaîne ces huit j'en ai un peu marre un
moment de me faire démolir en permanence
dans une certaine émission donc je vais
arrêter
j'ai décidé d'arrêter d'y aller zemmour
expriment des opinions politiques qui
sont très marqués aujourd'hui
et quand ces news engage sanary
quelqu'un de politique en plus avec des
propos qui mois
quand même pas mal choqué ces derniers
temps j'estime que c'est un engagement
pris de la part de ces news qui engage
sa rédaction en plus et pose problème et
donc je ne vais pas aller sur ces news
alors c'est 8c news +17 boycotter le
groupe canal et pillages alors sur sur
ces mots qui pense ici aux médias il
m'associe à zemmour et puis on va dire
michel cymes on est revenue sur ces
démissions plusieurs fois on donne notre
avis sur l'émission michel cymes fait ce
qui est dingue c'est que c'est
l'animateur préféré des français qui
n'est jamais on a regardé ce quiproquo
des taux d'audience à sepang a aimé mais
personne ne le regarde
non mais c'est quoi comme la célébrité
parfois faire ressortir le pire de
chacun et c'est grave parce que c'est
plutôt un monsieur qui a fait des études
de médecine frères et les gens caverni
la degrés s'est pris un melon pas
possible et aujourd'hui il a ce
sentiment de sueur pouvoir et ce sans
préféré des français il ne faut pas le
critiquer il faut pas le contredire
il faut pas aller contre lui arrive à
faire un one man show il se prend pour
jimmy fallon à 22h à la télévision voilà
il serait tellement plus sympathique si
redescende est un tout petit peu au
contraire qui viennent ici j'en sais
rien et je pense qu'il est sûr de venir
on serait ravi de le recevoir et battre
avec au sud
s'ils voulaient venir à nos frais oui on
a on a créé pas inquiet on a critiqué
michel cymes donc maintenant on est tous
des parias des battoirs vérifier qu'il
n'avait pas été qu'ils il de les lire
l'avis aussi fait pas pierre potier mais
c'est pas de note yann à quai mais
michel 13 c'est pas notre faute si fait
des émissions qui marchent pas je suis
désolé isabelle gilles disaient qu'ils
marchaient pas ces démissions mais on va
pas on va pas mentir parce que saint
michel c'est ce qui fait peur mais ça
marche pas ça marche pas eh bien oui
mais on donne des oignons c'est pas de
notre faute on est une émission médias
je n'accepte pas le jeu je suis désolé
m6 qu'anthony que ça marche pas ils
disent bon bah c'est vrai ça marche ça
prendrait des émissions qu'on dise ça
marche pas ça marche pas quand stelly
nous ont pas appelé parce qu'on a dit
que la course des héros n'avait pas
marché la course des champions
voilà donc lui déconvenue un truc sur
lui il appelle tout le monde voyait pas
ce qu'il appelle tout bas je vous dis il
appelle tout le monde dit oui cyril
hanouna venir mais michel on ne
t'inquiète pas voilà écouterait chez toi
continue à prendre ton stéthoscope
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête parce que j'aime bien c'est
quand j'aime bien les mecs moi qui ont
du courage
michel cymes je t'aime michel c je suis
puni je t'aime et je t'aime pas en fait
je m'en fous mais michel cymes je les
croisais dans un restaurant et parfois
et il vient et où il va y voit là il va
il fait le bouffon voilà il vient
également brasse et rick nash orwell
tout va bien je suis dit tout ne va pas
bien je suis désolé x donc voilà que ça
veut dire moi moi j'aime les mecs
vraiment voilà les courageux d'eau qui
vient et vient me voir il me parlait
c'est pas quand ils me croisent dans la
rue genre tout va bien et quand il parle
voilà sur d'autres temps d'autres
antennes il fait d'accord donc car il
doit bien vous croisez vos mots qui vous
en met une de ce que vous demande
exactement à d'accord là par contre
faudra que cela tue en un coup weekes du
fait qu'ils veulent pas venir ici parce
que bon ben je peux comprendre voilà il
va pas être bien accueilli forcément
voilà je suis au delà du fait qu'il
veuille pas aller dans face à venir ça
l'info ça on peut le comprendre on
n'invite pas de droit qui a rien qui va
gérer face d'eux et moi aussi
ce que je trouve injuste et même très
con c'est de mettre au ban de dons
d'englober tout le monde sait ça arrive
dans le groupe c'est à dire que tous les
journalistes à canal et dieu sait qui on
a beau bien sûr pas d'accord avec
l'arrivée de zemmour toutes les
émissions sur canal je pense à moulis je
pense à plein de gens j'ai donc tous ces
gens là il aimait dans le même sac les
dit voilà je vous emmerde tout ce temps
elle était en moi j'envisage d'ailleurs
j'y ai invités n'eut pas voilà on va
être le débat michel d'avoir quelqu'un
qui va te faire redescendre un petit peu
le melon con et tu quand tu auras plus
le melon ce sera le bienvenu mais vous
risquez de le croiser dimanche parce que
vous savez que c'est un grand amateur du
voyage mais il est toujours au parc et à
mon avis si vous y allez dimanche vous
allez le voir dans le derche inch'allah
je regarde canal qu'on le match est
retransmis quand même j'espère qu'ils
regardent canal quand les machines non
mais je crois que même pas après que le
prix cohérent aime pas mais pas une
déroute le match à la radio hier lors de
son émission justement face à l'info sur
ses news
eric zemmour a fait une nouvelle sortie
très controversée sur le passé colonial
de la france et particulièrement en
évoquant les massacres des musulmans oui
des juifs en algérie donc ce qui m'a le
plus énervée moi c'est que michel cymes
m'associe à zemmour voilà ça en plus ça
voilà il a fait exprès voilà mais
beaucoup ont été choqués par les propos
d'eric zemmour eu de belles photos
j'estime que quand on vient en france et
qu'on est français on doit changer son
point de vue et qu'on doit voir
l'histoire en fonction de l'intérêt de
la france
mais je veux dire par là un single le si
vous voulez quand le général du jour
arrive en algérie eh ben ils commencent
à massacrer les musulmans et même
certains juifs et ben moi je suis
aujourd'hui
du côté du général bugeaud c'est un
autre désaccord au ciné oui merci
beaucoup monsieur la 70e est ce qu'on
peut dire de dire qu'il était du côté du
général bugeaud
je rappelle 7h10 140 c'était bien avant
la guerre d'algérie que tout le monde
connaît et effectivement quand elle est
arrivée en algérie ce général bugeaud
c'était déjà à l'acte et les colonies
françaises qu'on essaie d'établir
partout il a massacré effectivement les
musulmans et les juifs
comment peut-on dire qu'il est de 2 du
côté de cet homme qui a était un
meurtrier c'est choquant c'est
inadmissible franchement c'est un grand
choc ce dont j'ai battu était quelque
chose là c'était la dernière minute
quand il fait cette petite phrase voilà
la semaine dernière quand il dit les
homosexuels choisissent leur sexualité
la dernière minute avant le générique
donc c'est donc un garçon qui prévoit
toujours une sortie à la faim extrême
maire joël extrêmement polémique
extrêmement provoque pour qu'on en parle
derrière c'est le talent et le vois pas
ce que on posera la question ce soir
qu'eric zemmour dont il reste à
l'antenne dans bâle en train de postes
voilà oui un deuxième sujet et sachez
qu'on italie le voir aussi pour savoir
pourquoi il n'était pas venu à
s'expliquer sur la noce conseillers ont
voulu faire bien et vous qui connaissez
le grand grand grand patron du groupe
j'adorerais savoir via vous ce que pense
monsieur bolloré d'un mélange coloris
sont claires à des hôtels
pas du tout pas du tout c'est serge
nejjar le poids car c'est nous et qui
lui a à tf1 c'est pas martin bouygues
il dit ce combat note à long terme soit
arrivé de donner son avis martin oui
c'est le propriétaire matin we did i pad
danse avec les stars vous mettez vous
mettez de christophe licata maigrir
marie bigard mais quand des missions
foligno énoncés nous saluons les
décisions mais sait il est complètement
libre et on le laisse complètement libre
dans le groupe c oui c'est sa chaîne
voilà si après on n'est pas d'accord et
l'oignon fait d'accord avec marc oui ok
dans le secret des dieux
malgré tout la case c'est mieux mais qui
séduit autant plus des mots 500 et vous
même dans mes skis sascoc normalement
quand même moi je trouve qu'au niveau de
l'argument terme tout ça sur it's on
with his hambourg il radote est toujours
dans l'autre jambe en faisant fi lière
il a fait encore 188 et spectateurs
c'est là un triplé karim et sans cyril
paraît-il mais je sais pour l'instant
afin que je suis d'accord mais bon en
tout cas il a triplé la casse et pour la
moyenne de la chaîne en termes la lâche
pas le fonctionnement interne à zola
d'affichage c'est mieux après voilà
chacun fait ce qu'il veut